das einfach traumhaft elitepartner ch
niveau
[Musik]
sie alle wollen auf und davon
die bündner sabrina und markus blume
tochter amira suchen das einfache leben
in der kanadischen wildnis vom zürcher
oberland nach kambodscha monika lehnert
und peter kruse erfüllen sich den traum
vom eigenen kleinen guesthouse carolin
schneider und daniel schafer aus dem
kanton bern zielen mit ihren städten
nach schweden wo sie eine campinganlage
führen
[Musik]
wer auswandert stellt sein leben auf den
kopf
[Musik]
doch selbst in der kanadischen wildnis
kehren bald wieder alltägliche rituale
zurück markus blume tod wasser jeden
morgen tut seit acht monaten wohnt
markus zusammen mit frau sabrina und
tochter amira am abgelegenen blickfeld
mittlerweile hat sich der bündner an die
harten lebensbedingungen in der
abgeschiedenheit gewinnt
außerdem denkt spricht auf seiner laune
zu sehen aber die märkte sind eigentlich
so dass eigenes risiko
aber das funktioniert in der letzten
folge war der blick noch nicht gefroren
die familie gingen die pferde ein mit
denen sie dereinst touren anbieten
wollen und sie richtete sich gemütlich
ein in ihrer kleinen holzhütte in
kambodscha machte geschäftspartner max
große probleme nach einer positiven
aussprache begannen monika lier peter
kruse einander den boden zu verlegen
doch die besitzerin pochte auf eine
bedeutend teurere variante mit der fähre
setzen carolin schneider und daniel
schafer nach schweden über nach vier
tagen fahrt mit knapp 20 schlittenhunden
immerhin erreichten sie endlich ihr
neues zuhause
[Musik]
vielleicht findet sich das kleine
familienglück leichter wenn man eng
aufeinander lebt sabrina bluhm die
mittlerweile drei jahre alt geworden und
vater markus sind happy mit ihren 20
quadratmetern wohnfläche ohne jeden
komfort auf fließend wasser und strom
lässt sich leichter verzichten wenn es
dafür im luna of love stimmt sabrina ist
im sechsten monat schwanger
einkaufstaschen muss sabrina hier oben
tatsächlich nicht retten denn der
nächste supermarkt liegt zwölf
autostunden entfernt nun bereitet sich
die familie blum darauf vor für ein paar
monate umzuziehen jedoch nicht näher zur
zivilisation sondern noch weiter weg
davon
dennoch ist die destination ist im
sommer tour und die technik ist entstand
stelle und zugleich möchte mit ihm
verbringen und das ziel der blues ist
eine völlig abgeschiedenen blog güter
die sie von einem früheren besuch kennen
natürlich mitte seine lebensmittel
wichtig ist und was seltsam wegen des
vielen gepäcks muss zwei mal geflogen
werden
markus preiß toraus seine liebsten
werden erst morgen nachfolgenden
abgeschiedenen die blues haben eine
mission sie wollen die güte so weit
vorbereiten dass sie im sommer touren in
dieser gegend anbieten können
[Musik]
der tag bricht an in der kanadischen
stadt dialog will
[Musik]
beim gasthaus wies gordon 34 die
hausangestellten ein
gut schweizerische tugenden gehören hier
zum geschäftsmodell klein dafür sauber
und gepflegt soll die unter kunst sein
für dieses ziel werde nun italien hat
und ihr partner peter preise in den
letzten drei wochen allerhand
unternommen
nicht zuletzt haben sie sich für den
teuren boden entschieden und damit
doppelt so viel geld ausgegeben wie
budgetiert töne produziert und richard
männer 23 uhr termes fernseher setzen
wir es ein abflüsse setzte also grüner
die user noch ein zähler fehlt macht ja
auf die krokodile von vormittag sind weg
nun schwimmen harmlose fischer entronnen
die offizielle eröffnung des gästehauses
findet zwar erst morgen statt die sechs
zimmer sind aber bereits gut gebucht
peters planung wird von der
hausangestellten tui unterbrochen
nein das heißt er das land kaputt
was ist kaputt der deutsche gast falco
hat sich beschwert
es gibt ein problem mit der air
condition und der warmwasserboiler ist
kaputt
ich bin deprimiert weil wir haben jetzt
mit jungs probiert aber zeigen stolz
darauf vertrauen fasst 16 gesetzte ist
der weg ja schon dass das auch gleich da
müssen wir jetzt auch machen kannst du
für die aircondition schauen
okay du gehst schauen den rest des
geldes bekomme ich wieder peter und
monika haben nur ein beschränktes budget
zur verfügung
der weg zum gepflegten suisse gaben wird
allerdings je länger ihr teuer
der deutsche vorgänger max hat das
gasthaus zu lange verlottern lassen
so funktionieren wie bemerkte der 100
musiker sehr schnell verkauft und mir
dafür dass die 100 iges elvis machen sei
die letzte tranche des handgriffs von
20.000 dollar überwiesen wurde
monika und peter nichts mehr von max
gehört dabei hat er nur rund einen
kilometer entfernt soeben eine chill out
area eröffnet
[Musik]
einen schöneren ersten morgen in ihrer
neuen schwedischen reibert hätten sich
die auswanderer nicht wünschen können
[Musik]
doch es ist ihnen nicht die zeit
vergönnt den prächtigen tag zu genießen
sie übernehmen die campinganlage sancho
baden im laufenden betrieb im
hauptgebäude der anlage lassen sich
karin schneider und daniel schafer von
der vorbesitzerin die kasse erklären
während mit auswanderer rolf kaiser in
der küche schon hat der arbeit ist im
keller erhalten karin und daniel eine
einführung in die holzheizung ein
kleiner ofen für das ganze haus
[Musik]
die vorbesitzerin hat die campinganlage
sancho gaarden fünf jahre lang geführt
gemeinsam mit ihrem mann nun will sie
aber zurück zu ihrer familie nach
südschweden
bald werden die auswanderer keine
weiteren fragen mehr stellen können
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das passt nicht schlecht zu einem
gebäude das früher als schulhaus genutzt
wurde
dann verlässt die vorbesitzerin santa
garten passen zum schweden klischee
steckt ihr hab und gut in einer ikea
tasche nun sind die schweizer
auswanderer auf sich allein gestellt
noch ist es ein leben die der schwebe
die hunde haben noch keinen wolf wartet
nicht nur auf frau und kind sondern auch
auf den möbeln transporter
carolin und daniel leben im wohnwagen
ins haus muss umgebaut werden und ist
noch nicht bezugsbereit
[Musik]
sabrina bluhm befindet sich im anflug
einen tag haben sie und ihre tochter
wegen des schlechten wetters warten
müssen
nach einem 20 minütigen flug sehen sie
ihr ziel vor sich den zugefrorenen
capital inc
[Musik]
mappus blumen erwartet die beiden es ist
die wiederkehr an einen ort den die
blums vor anderthalb jahren schon einmal
besucht haben damals sommer und sie
befanden sich auf einem zweieinhalb
monate langen pferde tracking
nun wollen sie hier den winter
verbringen versteckt am waldrand liegt
eine kleine blockhütte die vor knapp 20
jahren vom französischen abenteurer
nicola vanier erbaut wurde
er lebte mit frau und kleinkind in der
wildnis kanadas und hat ein buch darüber
geschrieben
die grünen schließen sich davon
inspirieren und wohnen in ihren eigenen
traum leben
[Musik]
die hand
also es ist einfach niemand weit und
breit
wegen des wm oks bsc entgegen
deswegen ganz speziell das einfach mal
gemeinde berge botox ist der kemberger
der name das bissige und für die schweiz
wird beleuchtet
jeder werkelt einfach einnahmen sind die
menschen die den bergen namen geben um
mit ihnen vertraut zu werden
doch hier rät im umkreis von 200
kilometern keine andere menschen seele
als jene der familie blum
[Musik]
wir besuchen
kein vergleich zum monika tieren als
früheren leben als modeberaterin im
künstlich beleuchteten einkaufszentrum
und auch der ehemalige zugbegleiter
peter kruse holte sich mit seiner arbeit
keine gesunde farbe
nun führen die beiden ein eigenes
gasthaus und sind stets auf der suche
wie sie den standort ihres kaders weiter
heben können entschuldigung ist es
wirklich so einem ding
der drehende wischmopp überzeugt die
reinlichen schweizer auswanderer der
putzeimer wird gekauft
ich bezahle nicht mehr
ich lebe zwar ist wenig 2000 nicht mehr
nein nein denn ich lebe hier zwei dollar
zu einem ja oder nein
[Musik]
monika und peter haben den neuen putz
einer nicht für sich gekauft sondern für
die beiden hausangestellten tui und
paris
die beiden frauen erhalten 100 dollar
pro monat für kambodscha ein
überdurchschnittlicher lohn
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das durch das der campinganlage seynsche
baden am nächsten liegt heißt blatnik
saale und hat gerade mal 200 einwohner
es ist eine dünn besiedelte gegend in
der sich die auswanderer niedergelassen
haben
während die beiden männer die technik in
der küche ausprobieren nimmt carolin
schneider den allerersten telefonanruf
entgegen
[Musik]
ok um 6 wie heißt es so schön
[Gelächter]
manchmal hat selbst caroline keine
chance gegen die männerfreundschaft von
daniel und weniger lang stories about
the future
und hier mit großen sozialen problemen
konnten schau des berger also wir sie
sicher nicht
beginn ist einfach entschlossen dass
wenn wir ein problem das es war das
gemeinsame hobby der schlittenhunde
welches daniel und roche zusammen
brachte zum einzigartigen wesen von
hunden gehört dass man sich ihrer ewigen
treue gewiss sein
menschliche freundschaften dagegen
können unversehens tiefe risse erhalten
[Musik]
die familie blum richtet sich wieder
einmal ihr leben ein
auch am tag wieder weg braucht es ein
wasser
[Musik]
das notification das ist nicht es geht
weiter raus wo der sie genügend tief ist
und aufgewirbelte boden drückt das
wasser nicht verunreinigt
also sind es 37 trink trink wasser das
erste grundbedürfnis der familie blum
ist abgedeckt
doch noch fehlen ein paar
annehmlichkeiten
[Musik]
45 grad wärmer am anderen ende der welt
peter kruse gönnt sich ein bad in dir
der 49 jährige scheint zufrieden mit
sich und der welt
[Musik]
minute mal mehr grüßen
wenige meter vom strand entfernt ihn
gestern fluss baden monika bereitet die
offizielle eröffnung vor es soll ein
gemütlicher der kommunikative peta setzt
mehr auf mund-zu-mund-propaganda auch in
der strandbar des kapuziners taub es ist
ein nationaler feiertag
und deshalb sind schon früh viele
einheimische dar
monika entschließt sich spontan eine
öffnung schild zu schreiben um
vielleicht doch noch ein paar leute mehr
an die eröffnung zu locken
nein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
lauter konzentration auf die
schönschrift ist beim burggarten dass
die vergessen gegangen
wo die auswanderer nicht aufgegeben
haben
das fehlende team ist man geschickt
aufgeklebt
[Musik]
regen in schweden darnell kein swinger
existiert müssen die schlittenhunde in
die boxen auf dem anhänger und trocken
zu bleiben
die gitter elemente für den finger
liegen schon bereit aber der schwedische
bauunternehmer findet einfach keine zeit
das fundament zu legen bis der züge
wurden kommt unternehmen daniel schafer
und carolin schneider einen ausflug zu
einem ruf wie der nachbarschaft ihre
hündin aber liegt derzeit hier
sie wurde noch in der schweiz trächtig
und da der geburtstermin der welten just
meter auswanderung zusammenfiel wurde
ohne aber schon früher nach schweden
gebracht zu einem befreundeten
hundehalter 19 die hundebabys sechs an
der zahl
sie sind gerade mal zwölf tage alt
gaulin und daniel die welpen zum ersten
mal aber das macht die messe hier 17 20
uhr und um feststehen
solange in sant'agata die zwingeranlage
noch nicht steht ist da war mit grillgut
hier besser auf die roma
[Musik]
die familie blum begibt sich auf einen
rundgang um geräte dabei stößt sie auf
die überreste eines plumpsklos die drei
brauchen nicht nur für sich ein klo
sondern auch für die gäste die einst
kommen sollen
für den sommer planen die blumes pfähle
trekkingtouren zur tschakert jeder hütte
anzubieten und zu ihr geld zu verdienen
nun ist die zeit die infrastruktur
herzurichten
[Musik]
mappus wird dann die touristen mit den
pferden surtec ebtida hütte führen
während sabrina für das leibliche wohl
der gäste besorgt ist
zurück in der blockhütte richtet sabrina
die küche ein
rund 100 kilogramm es waren muss sie
verstauen vorwiegend reis mehl zucker
salz aber auch ein paar konserven
markus macht sich am alten ofen zu
schaffen
das kamin rohr ist durchgerostet und
muss ersetzt werden
[Musik]
das sporne sabrina will auf das dach
steigen um den schnee weg zu schaufeln
[Gelächter]
es ist erstaunlich wie sehr sich sabrina
ins zeug legt obwohl sie im sechsten
monat schwanger ist
die blues haben ein satellitentelefon
und ein notsignal dabei mit dem sie
hilfe einfliegen lassen könnten
sabrina hat zwar gesagt dass die schwere
arbeit nur noch bei markus liege aber
beim einbau des ofens müsse weiter
anpacken
die zeit drängt es wert hier oben
schnellt dunkel und dann sehr kalt
es beginnt zu dem man die arbeiten
ziehen sich hin
die temperatur liegt mittlerweile bei
minus 15 grad
[Musik]
[Applaus]
monika lehnert die letzten ballone für
die eröffnung auf sie ist kaum fertig
mit der dekoration da kommt auch schon
der erste gast
es ist ausgerechnet max der mann von dem
sie das gästehaus übernommen haben und
der ihnen einen harzigen start in ihrer
neuen heimat bereitete monikas begrüßung
ist nicht eben herzlich peter warten
guten anstand willkommen
es ist erst einen monat her als max rote
die übergabe des gasthauses an monika
und peter platzen zu lassen
dazu kam es zwar nicht doch wollte
wissen die beiden schweizer auswanderer
der übernahmepreis war nicht fair
es zeichnet also 258 selbst aber das ist
das problem
peter lässt mag sitzen er muss sich um
das wohl der weiteren gäste können
für die kambodschanischen besucher mag
die musik ein wenig befremdlich sein
fast heimisch dagegen führen sich die
deutschsprachigen auswanderer mit ihren
freundinnen die an jedem eröffnungsfest
in dialog will auftauchen sie auch
gratis bier bekommen von den schweizer 0
ankömmlingen aber nur kaffee und kuchen
kostenlos serviert
es bleibt nicht lange
für peter kein großer verlust
[Musik]
sie gehen jetzt abgrenzen zu wecken
peter wirkt erleichtert das kapitel max
abschließen zu können freut und
überrascht
ob es ist ja bei vorwärts positiv ich
danke gut machen wir das was vor ein
schlussstrich zu neustadt
wer nicht nachtragend ist kann besser
nach vorne blicken
[Musik]
in schweden trifft der zügel transporter
ein mit 88 kisten und mit daniel
scharfes professioneller 6000 franken
teuren schneefräse doch etwas fährt der
schlüssel ohne laufenden motor macht die
350 kilogramm schwere schneefräse gleich
weniger spaß
morgen öffnet schnappt punkt aber die
wissen was mit geschick zu lasch mit los
mit dem flexi ii gesetz zur mitte aber
in werkstatt und die hat der logische
schluss zu haben fragt was wir brauchen
haben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der schaut nochmals im auto noch ohne
erfolg
[Musik]
endlich taucht der schlüssel auf dort wo
in caroline von anfang an vermutet
die letzte sache zum glück bringt die
schneefräsen denn auch in schweden
konnte winkler scheinbar
[Musik]
markus blum ist in der zunehmenden
dämmerung über noch mit dem ofenrohr
beschäftigt die zeit läuft langsam davon
[Musik]
nicht dass ich auch
das ist ja oder nein - denn den
aufschlag weiter ohne dass ich kreis
sowie und das sind wir aber endlich das
offen ruhe kann eingesetzt werden und es
passt nun kann an das letzte
grundbedürfnis gedacht werden das essen
[Musik]
das einfache leben haben die blues
gesucht und just in diesem moment
scheint ihr wunsch vollkommen zu sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die eröffnung vom wiesbaden war ein
erfolg den gelungenen tag bonn monika
und peter am strand ausklingen lassen
die kambodschaner schießen emsig
feuerwerk in die meeresluft hinaus es
ist immer noch nationaler feiertag
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da ist glück bringen soll zünden monika
und peter rauch 2 feuerwerk stangen an
ja ja ja
[Musik]
in der nächsten sendung wird die ordnung
jedoch kurzzeitig verloren
peter und monika gehalten ihn stress den
das gasthaus ist voll ausgebucht in
schweden kette ein und die hunde haben
endlich einen zwinger das polarlicht
verzaubert die auswanderer
bald dürfte und in kanada zeigt sich das
wilde leben von der sonnenseite
doch dann kommt die schwangere sabrina
an ihr limit wichtigste buch dran
[Musik]